one division is one hell of a weird show
and whether you love it or just plain
confused you'll want to know how it
connects with the rest of the mcu
and like any great mystery there are a
ton of clues that reveal the show's
connections to the avengers spider-man
and even the x-men
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm explaining the weirdest and
most perplexing scenes
theories mcu references and easter eggs
in one division
plus i'll explain the new phase 4
villains like mephisto and grim reaper
that we can expect to see
in the show spoilers and speculation
ahead of course
setting the town of west view one
division takes place in a strange new
sitcom reality that wanda appears to
have created for herself
a clue that wander and vision are living
inside their own bubble reality or
pocket dimension
is the curious design of vision's tie
with two dots inside a rectangle with
two more dots on the outside
and given the sword encampment that's
been set up in this wooded area and a
strange energy field nearby
it suggests that wanda may have taken
over a town with her powers
this would explain why the real world
occasionally seems to leak
into wander's alternate reality such as
when a voice on the radio calls out to
wander
and when dottie asks who she really is
who are you
a similar moment happens when mr hart is
choking at the dinner table and his wife
tells him over and over to stop it
although this instruction seems to be
almost directed towards wonder instead
stop
it stop it stop it
it's a very weird and creepy moment
especially as after vision uses his
phasing ability to pull out the food
everyone seems to forget that anything
happened and they leave
i think that wanda may be using her
reality bending or illusion inducing
powers that we saw her use in age of
ultron against the avengers to maintain
the sort of idealized world she's
created for herself in west view
it appears that characters can actually
get hurt though such as when dottie cuts
her hand and we see the blood in
actual colour by the way the voice on
the radio sounds a lot like randall park
aka jimmy wu from ant-man and the wasp
who we know is now working for sword in
one division
sword is the acronym for the sentient
weapon observation and response division
and you can see they're the ones
monitoring wander and vision at the end
of the first episode
it also suggests that the agency views
wander and or vision to be sentient
weapons that could pose a threat there's
also a deep cut easter egg in this scene
referencing the wider mcu multiverse
when the fake credits for the one
division show roll by and we see the
name of the director is abe brown
one of peter parker's classmates abe was
a spider-man character
who survived the snap and this suggests
that he's now working for sword
and it might even point to wanda
appearing in the next mcu spider-man
movie given we know she's already in
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness especially as spider-man 3 will
be featuring the spider-man multiverse
with appearances from alfred molina's
doc arc and jamie foxx's electro
there's certainly a lot more to wander's
nosey neighbor than she's letting on and
given we see her dressed as a witch
later in the series many fans are
assuming she's playing the comic book
character agatha harkness a witch from
salem
especially as her name agnes combines
the first and last syllables of agatha
harkness
however i think this may be almost too
obvious and marvel's planning a little
twist
and she turns out to be mephisto one of
phase four's next big villains
one of the clues is in how she reacts to
dottie in this scene the devil's in the
details bev
that's not the only place he is and then
she has a pet rabbit called senor
scratchy which is a big clue because mr
scratch is a nickname for the devil
this might also be a reference to
agnes's son in the comics nicholas
scratch a major fantastic four super
villain
agnes even draws attention to scratch
his importance
senor scratchy just loves the stage he
played baby jesus in last year's
christmas pageant
for those unfamiliar mephisto is an
extremely powerful demonic villain who
rules a pocket dimension called hell in
the comics and who seems set to become
an important villain in the mcu given
the prominent display of a devil in a
stained glass window in the loki trailer
it's also interesting that agnes
constantly jokes in the show about her
husband ralph who we mysteriously
haven't seen yet
the only way ralph would remember our
anniversary as if there was a beer named
june
2nd the name ralph is significant
because he's a character from
christopher marlowe's play dr
faustus who helped conjure devil such as
mephistopheles who the marvel villain
mephisto is based on and named after
another mystery in the show is the
identity of the beekeeper who climbs out
of a sewer at the end of the second
episode
a clue from a new featurette shows that
this appears to be a sword agent
being sent into the pocket dimension
that wander and vision are in as you can
see him crawling through a tunnel and
then his hazmat suit changes into a
beekeeper's costume
why a beekeeper though well although it
may be a reference to the marvel super
villain swarm whose body's made up of
bees
these themselves actually have some
specific symbolism that's very
appropriate to one division
as pollinators they're frequently
associated with fertility and
reproduction and so
linked to wanda's pregnancy and in
celtic mythology bees are regarded as
messengers between heaven and earth or
different realms which is also
fitting because the beekeeper's arrival
seems to be an attempt from the world
outside to make contact with wonder
wonder either consciously or intuitively
understands this and when she sees him
she says no
and rewinds time back to the moment when
she asks vision if this is really
happening
and this time rather than going outside
she transforms their world into a now
colour-filled sitcom reality
wanda being able to rewind time here for
a do-over reminds me of how vision died
twice in infinity war when thanos
rewound time to
undo wander's destruction of the mind
stone so that he could take the infinity
stone for himself
more on wonders time manipulation powers
shortly the know that wonder says to the
beekeeper may also be a reference to
wanda's famous line
no more mutants from the house of m
storyline in which scarlet witch caused
almost
every mutant to lose their powers
marvel's studios might be looking to
subvert this
iconic comic book moment by having one
to be the gateway to bringing mutants
and the x-men into the mcu
so look out for her saying more mutants
later in the series
and there's another neat reference to
the house of m via the wine
served at wanda's dinner party the
bottle's label reads maison du maypri
which translates to english as house of
contempt plus there's a letter
m around the neck of the bottle and one
division's credits are a cool visual nod
to the way wanda's mental breakdown in
the comics
is represented by her disintegrating
reality into blocks
there are some especially creepy moments
in the second episode when the various
residents of west view chant
four the children together
there's mrs hart who badges wonder and
vision about why they don't have
children
and the headline on the newspaper that
vision reads says little baby june's
first words tickle mother sue
agnes also seems to be very keen on
getting wanda to seduce vision in the
first episode what about seduction
techniques
and dottie is another mysterious
character intent on pushing the for the
children agenda
on top of that it's particularly
disturbing that there aren't even any
children around in any of these scenes
however all of these pressures seem to
have worked into brainwashing the couple
by the end of episode two
and just like that as if by magic wanda
discovers she's pregnant
perhaps because she simply decided it it
feels like there's some strange presence
at work here lurking in the background
such as mephisto who could be looking to
take control of wanda's children who
will undoubtedly be superpowered when
they're born
in the comics when wanda has children
she discovers her the outcome of her
magic mixing with fragments of mephisto
soul
now the mcu won't be following the comic
book storylines exactly however it often
takes elements and inspiration from them
so it's quite likely that mephisto has
something to do with wanda's pregnancy
and children
it's also possible that wanda made a
bargain with the devil to bring vision
back to life and he'll later try to
collect on the deal by taking away her
children
is that what the voice means when it
asks wonder who's doing this to you
the fake ad breaks also provide some
more clues as to what may be going on in
wanda's mind and how she may be
processing the various traumas she's
experienced in her life
the watch commercial advertising struck
her watches is of course a reference to
baron von strucker the hydra leader who
experimented on wanda and her brother
pietro with the mine stone
struck her he'll make time for you
but this is more than just an easter egg
for marvel fans as i think it's implying
that wanda may have inherited more
powers than we realized from the mind
stone
including the ability to manipulate and
rewind time which she did after seeing
the beekeeper
and there was another awesome hydra
easter egg cleverly hidden on the
wallpaper in wanda's home
as she turns everything to colour you
can see the sokovian hydra research base
where wander and her brother were kept
and which the avengers attacked at the
beginning of age of ultron
again this is wander's way of processing
this particular trauma
the ad for a toast mate 2000 by stark
industries is another traumatic
reference for wanda because remember
that she had an intense hatred for stark
after one of his bombs killed her
parents
and listened very carefully during the
commercial because the noise that the
toaster makes is the same
sound effect the iron man's blaster
makes as it powers up
and the uncomfortable look on the
housewife's face as she waits for the
bread to toast
may be a nod to how wanda and pietro
spent two days staring at stark's bomb
waiting for it to go off
we wait for two days for tony stark to
kill us
the message at the end of the ad forget
the past this is your future
seems to indicate that wanda is trying
to suppress her painful memories and
traumas through this new reality she's
created
if you're wondering where monica rambo
is in one division well she's already
appeared on the show but her character
is currently called geraldine
i'm wanda i'm a geraldine
i actually don't know what i'm doing
here the loud crash that wander and
vision here at night at the beginning of
the second episode is a sword helicopter
that i think monica rambo was piloting
but which crashed through to west view
from the world outside
and it's represented by the red toy
helicopter that wander picks up the next
day with a sword logo on it there's a
clever reference to this in the magic
trick that vision and wander performed
later that day
when geraldine's teleported from behind
the stage into the cabinet of mysteries
and by the way a cool detail here on the
cabinet artwork is the mind stone which
looks like it could be exploding
referencing how wanda destroyed the mind
stone in vision's forehead and infinity
war
again this may be another way that
wanda's processing another traumatic
event from her life i also think it's
interesting that vision refers to
himself as an illusion in this scene of
course it did the trick right i'm an
illusion
a possible bit of foreshadowing that
this version of vision may not be who he
seems to be at first
in fact in a recent trailer i noticed
that wander and vision are facing off
against
each other so could vision himself even
turn out to be the villain of one
division
he is dead after all in the real world
so could this vision
actually be a villain like mephisto in
disguise and as illusion's magic
assistant wanda is called glamour
perhaps hinting that a glamour or spell
has been cast on her or vision to hide
whatever's really going on
and this might be a stretch but the way
that each episode ends with wand and
vision enclosed in a hexagon
might also be suggesting that a hex has
been put on her a hex being an evil
spell that brings bad luck and trouble
on top of that a hexagon is also six
sided a hint perhaps to the devil's
number
666 together with the fact that this
radio is strangely missing a six
and of course honeycombs are also often
made up of hexagonal formations a
potential reference to the mysterious
beekeeper then
a few other easter eggs you might have
missed which may be significant include
the grim reaper's helmet in the second
episode's opening credits
the grim reaper is a marvel comics
villain and is rumored to be appearing
in one division
plus as a possible easter egg to wonder
man grim reaper's brother in the credits
here
so what do you think of one division and
what are your favorite theories about
the show
leave your thoughts in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this leave a
thumbs up i really appreciate it
tap left for my next marvel video on my
theory about black widow's secret twist
or tap right for something else you're
sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers